je crois
conférence sur les armements chimiques à
paris dès la première séance l'iran
accuse l'irak qui répond à quito
remplace son père hirohito sur le trône
impérial japonais l'enfant en riront
into est mort à l'âge de 87 ans après 63
ans de règne controversé le plus connu
de tous les théâtres français le
châtelet commence une nouvelle carrière
l'occasion pour nous de refaire
l'histoire de ce haut lieu de l'opérette
avec bien sûr son prince charmant luis
mariano un dossier à la fin de ce
journal
madame monsieur bonsoir
heureusement de temps en temps les
hommes se rendent compte qu'ils sont
allés trop loin dans le développement de
leur génie maléfique
ainsi peut-on comprendre le sens de la
réunion qui rassemble 145 pays ce week
end à paris pour tenter d'interdire
l'utilisation des armements chimiques
qui font peu à peu leur réapparition
alors qu'ils sont déjà interdits et cela
depuis le traité de genève
en 1925 le problème supplémentaires
posés par ces armes
c'est qu'elles ne sont pas le seul
apanage des grandes puissances les pays
les plus pauvres peuvent les fabriquer
ou les acheter à bon prix la preuve qui
est également le point de départ de la
réunion d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'utilisation récente de ces armements
chimiques dans le conflit entre l'iran
et l'irak
les représentants des deux pays se sont
d'ailleurs vivement accroché dès la
première séance cet après midi georges
bortoli philippe pétain dans une
conférence qui avait commencé sur le ton
de la sérénité
le discours du ministre des affaires
étrangères iranien a apporté une note
plus passionnés monsieur velayati a
déclaré que l'irak a utilisé pendant
huit ans contre son pays des armes
chimiques qui ont touché 50 mille
iranien dont 5000 sont morts d'après lui
des armes chimiques relativement
primitive utiliser son corps en 1984
l'irak est arrivé en 1987 à des missiles
répandant des gaz beaucoup plus de
meurtre
lui répondant depuis son banc un délégué
de l'irak lui a retourné son attaque
pour lui des irakiens ont également été
soumis à des attaques chimiques de la
part des iraniens
vous êtes les derniers at il dit à
pouvoir parler des droits de l'homme
vous avez commis des crimes contre
l'humanité cette horrible conflit irak
iran
cet emploi de l'armé chimique monsieur
mitterrand il y avait fait allusion chez
matin mais c'était pour en tirer une
conclusion pour l'avenir il ne s'agit
pas d'oublier mais d'inscrire dans le
droit l'engagement qui n'en sera plus
jamais ainsi votre présence ici montre
que la conscience du danger est très
largement partagée et profondément vécu
on sait qu'en raison de la nature man de
larmes chimiques la sécurité de tous et
de chacun exige son élimination complète
et vérifier cette conférence se tient
dans une circonstance à la fois ron est
mauvaise mauvaise parce que la guerre du
golfe a élu s'est tragiquement la montée
du péril de la guerre chimique est bonne
parce qu'il ya tout de même dans le
monde actuellement une tendance générale
au désarmement sous toutes ses formes
les deux grands ne sont ils pas en train
en ce moment même de détruire une partie
petite partie de leurs armements
nucléaires
alors si on détruit les armes nucléaires
il n'est pas absurde de penser qu'on
pourra un jour des fruits aussi les
armes chimiques dans l'enceinte
officielle des diplomates
vous les avez vues dans la rue à paris
aujourd'hui des représentants des
victimes du kurdistan dont une partie de
la population a été bombardée au gaz
chimiques par l'aviation irakienne dans
le courant de l'année dernière bilan
plusieurs dizaines de morts et des
blessés qui porteront toute leur vie des
traces de ces gaz chimiques
interdite en 1925 par un traité
international ces armes chimiques firent
peu à peu je vous disais tout à l'heure
leur réapparition après la deuxième
guerre mondiale vietnam afghanistan est
tout près de nous donc le conflit entre
l'iran et l'irak c'est donc pour éviter
une nouvelle banalisation de ce type
d'armement que cette réunion
internationale de paris a été décidé
mais rappelons-nous si l'on remonte dans
l'histoire c'est en 1915 en belgique
dans les tranchées de la région d'ypres
que pour la première fois les allemands
utilisaient des gaz contre les troupes
alliées patrice peur nous avons reçus et
leur demande au but qui nous paraissait
prêt créteil réalité c'était des obus à
gave et ce gaz
c'était en réalité un vivier de
l'ypérite qui se veut favoriser l'autre
mot et surtout pénétrer à l'intérieur
des abris cet ancien combattant parle de
la terrible réalité de la guerre
chimique des milliers d'autres comme lui
aurait pu dire la même chose s'il en
était revenus entre 1914 et 1918 un
million de soldats seront gazés
cent mille mort ou sur le champ de
bataille ou plus tard à l'hôpital
ensuite les gars vont se succéder et
l'armé chimique continuera d'être
employé 1939 1945
les seize gaz des centaines de milliers
d'hommes et de femmes le gaz de combat
au service d'une idéologie
vietnam les bombardiers américains
survolent la forêt afghanistan les
hélicoptères tirs sur les moudjahidine
réfugiés dans les villages iran irak
le massacre des kurdes précipitera la
fin d'une guerre qui aura duré quatre
ans pourtant en juin 1925 le protocole
de genève visait à prohiber à tout
jamais l'emploi d'armes chimiques sur
les champs de bataille et de plus étant
dé cette interdiction aux moyens de
guerre bactériologique un protocole
jamais appliqué au contraire depuis
cette date rien n'a empêché la mise au
point la production et le stockage
d'armes chimiques sur la planète
un exemple cet obus deux produits
presque inoffensif au départ ce mélange
pendant la trajectoire du projectile le
produit mortel se répand au moment de
l'impact
contrairement au nucléaire il reste
cependant possible de se défendre contre
larmes chimiques la détection d'un gaz
peut se faire sur place
grâce à ces boîtiers portatif ou à
distance avec les détecteurs
automatiques d'armes chimiques les
civils comme les militaires peuvent se
protéger
masques vêtements isolant le moindre
geste devient alors pénible cet
équipement doit être portée s'il le faut
pendant des heures voire des jours le
prix de la survie
aujourd'hui c'est en millions de tonnes
qu'il faut compter les stocks d'armes
chimiques dans le monde
en rapport direct avec la réunion de
paris aujourd'hui à tripoli en libye le
colonel kadhafi menace de menacer de
représailles par les états unis qui
n'accepte pas la présence d'une usine
d'armement chimiques sur son territoire
eh bien le colonel kadhafi a rencontré
les journalistes actuellement présents
en libye sur son invitation d'ailleurs
une rencontre à la manière kadhafi c'est
à dire surprenante le colonel s'en
prenant très durement aux états unis
devant lesquels il n'a pas l'intention
de plier même s'ils réclament une
négociation directe avec washington
gilles rabin france brice kadhafi le
révolutionnaire débarquant sans prévenir
dans l'hôtel où sont retenus malgré eux
les journalistes occidentaux
cela donne et de bousculades quasi
impérialistes commentaires irréelle du
colonel je suis juste venu boire un café
je ne savais pas que vous étiez la
strada fille tente de s'installer
successivement dans deux des trois
salons de l'hôtel puis renonce et
improvise une conférence de presse qu
troina couloir le colonel parle arabe
posez vos questions en arabe en réalité
le colonel de répondre à aucune question
il s'en tiendra à une déclaration c'est
réaffirmant que les américains seraient
show to start u10 que les libyens
avaient je cite la patience des poissons
et qu'il saurait attendre leur heure
pour répliquer comme il se doit à
l'arrogance américaine
fin de citation place pourront nous
visiter l'usiné chimique de rapt à ada
fille ne répond pas quand pourrons-nous
aller sur place dès que possible
consent à dire le colonel
la dizaine de gardes du corps en
treillis vert est dépassé par
l'événement bref échange musclé avec
quelques militants de comités populaires
a couru pour acclamer la sortie du grand
leader de la grande jamahiriya libyenne
kadhafi parvient enfin à sa voiture
il conduit lui-même seul aux commandes à
l'âge de 87 ans l'empereur du japon
hirohito vient de décéder des suites
d'un cancer son règne aura duré soixante
trois ans son agonie 100 jours
exactement dieu vivant à son
couronnement en 1926 chef d'une
puissance militaire qui voulu étendre sa
domination sur l'asie tout entière et le
pacifique vient il termina sa vie ont
souvent retraités de la deuxième
puissance économique du monde
dès ce matin son fils le nouvel empereur
akihito a pris sa succession à l'âge de
54 ans jean bart qui dosent 23h03 hier
soir à tokyo shoichi fujimori grand
chambellan de la maison impériale
annonce que sa majesté hirohito empereur
du japon sans 24e du nom vient de
s'éteindre paisiblement au terme
pourtant 211 jours d'acharnement
thérapeutique et d'un cancer de
l'intestin dès 22h40 radios et
télévisions japonaises posté depuis le
19 septembre devant le palais de
l'empereur agonisant avaient interrompu
leurs programmes pour annoncer que le
médecin de l'empereur et que le prince
héritier akihito venait d'être appelé
précipitamment au palais ce n'est qu'une
fois le décès impérial officiellement
confirmé que commencera un long ballet
de limousines au gré de l'hommage rendu
chacun à son tour par les autres membres
de la famille impériale
mais déjà au cours d'une brève cérémonie
de quatre minutes
les objets sacrés attaché au trône du
chrysanthème sont remis dans un silence
total au nouvel empereur
le prince héritier a quito une épée des
bijoux et laisse aux impériaux et
nationaux qui confère à l'héritier les
pouvoirs symbolique mais sacré que
l'histoire et la religion prête à
l'empereur incarnation plus que deux
fois millénaire de l'identité et des
vertus du japon éternelle
encore aujourd'hui la personne de
l'empereur se confond avec la mémoire du
japon même si depuis la défaite du
fascisme ou japonais il a renoncé à son
essence divine à toute forme d'
influence politique
son décès est perçu comme un deuil
familial
à tokyo hommage posthume et registre de
condoléances dans un froid glacial 120
millions de japonais qui le temps d'un
rite sacrifie un à l'instant au passé
leur soif effrénée de futures il y
aurait eu tôt vous l'aurez compris en
définitive un personnage ambigu alliée
de l'allemagne nazie solidaire de la
sauvagerie de ses troupes sur le
continent asiatique
en 1945 il ne dut qu'à l'intervention du
général américain macarthur de ne pas
être traité en criminel de guerre comme
les autres ce dieu vivant accepta alors
de redescendre en quelque sorte sur
terre pour continuer un reign discret
sans pouvoir réel mais garant du
maintien de l'unité japonaise thierry
calmette
un couple de retraités dans leur jardin
les dernières images de l'empereur
hirohito avant sa maladie 1901 l'enfance
d'un chef pour ces sujets ils étaient
nos le seigneur du ciel pour l'occident
le mikado héritier d'une dynastie
vieille de 23 siècle dieu vivant élevé
dans la langue des traditions des
samouraïs
c'est précepteur des généraux
farouchement nationaliste l'étiquette
recommande de s'adresser à lui qu avec
stupeur et tremblements à 21 ans
voyagent en europe pour la première fois
de sa vie il voit un billet de banque de
paris il gardera un souvenir un ticket
de métro et hiro hito accède au trône en
1926 les prêtres bâti son règne peu
éclairé en fait c'est la période de
l'expansionnisme militaires japonais
complice et inspirateur des généraux
d'extrême droite ou bien manipulé par
eux hirohito laisse conquérir la
mandchourie massacrer les populations en
chine s'allie avec hitler et mussolini
celle axe pour la conquête du monde
1941 pearl harbor la deuxième guerre
mondiale
quatre ans plus tard bombe atomique
américaine sur hiroshima et nagasaki
foudroyé le peuple japonais écoute
l'empereur qui annonce la capitulation
et le découvre humilié aux côtés du
général macarthur triomphant et
décontractée macarthur lui évite de
justesse le tribunal pour crimes de
guerre contre l'abandon de tous ses
pouvoirs
en 1946 le souverain renonce à son
essence divine
trente ans plus tard il ira même jusqu'à
visiter disneyland 62 ans de règne une
passion la biologie marine
hirohito un symbole de paix pour le
nouveau japon qui possède désormais pour
arm le travail
la technologie et la finance l'actualité
en france 7 encore la sphère pechiney ce
samedi quelques noms nouveaux sont
apparus aujourd'hui dans le quotidien le
monde personnes ou sociétés qui auraient
bénéficié d'informations leur permettant
d'acheter à bon compte des actions de la
société américaine rachetée par péchiney
et de les revendre à meilleur compte
encore aux deux noms déjà connus des
proches du président de la république
monsieur mitterrand est une société
financière
selon le journal le monde aujourd'hui
forêt a ajouté la société de bourse
magnin cordelle et une charge d'agent de
change luxembourgeoise pétrus sécurities
et enfin une société américaine drexel
burnham lambert la ferc ans on n'a pas
avancé hier soir malgré une
confrontation de plus de dix heures
entre la principal inculpé de captation
d'héritage madame pinel et celui qu'elle
accuse aujourd'hui d'avoir tout organisé
m lombard isabelle staes 0 heures 30 ce
matin malgré la fatigue m lombard a le
sourire il sort libre du cabinet du juge
bernard après 10 heures d'interrogatoire
accusé par joël pennel d'être
l'instigateur de la captation d'héritage
la dernière confrontation semble avoir
tourné à l'avantagé de l'avocat
marseillais
aucune
l'accusation n'a aujourd'hui trouver le
moindre point
il faut donc considérer que ces
accusations sont aussi fragiles lors de
son arrivée hier au palais de justice
joue alpes enel avait une nouvelle fois
clamé son innocence
son avocat maître vergès affirmé quant à
lui que l'instigateur de la sphère était
forcément un juriste certitude affichée
hier soir ce matin pourtant le défenseur
de joël quesnel avait perdu le sourire
aux clients son rôle apparaît comme un
rôle beaucoup plus modeste
- diabolique comme dati elle est apparue
assez glawdys elle encore aires communes
tube
une jupe qui ne sait pas du tout ce
qu'on a fait de l'argent au gouvernement
a versé aux autos le juge bernard a
bouclé cette nuit son travail sur
l'instruction de cette affaire qui dure
déjà depuis deux ans muté à lille
le magistrat rejoindra mercredi sa
nouvelle affectation
c'est un confrère toulonnais qui hérite
du dossier quand ce we dernier élément à
verser au dossier ce soir la gendarmerie
a présenté ce samedi
94 faux tableaux dont un renoir peint
par la principale accule paix dont on
vient de parler madame pesnel
le tableau qui ont été présentés au juge
d'instruction jean-pierre berne
tremblement de terre dans le sud ouest
de la france il ya soir à 20h33 très
exactement et pendant une quinzaine de
secondes des pyrénées à la limite des
bouches du rhône pas de blessés ni de
dégâts apparents mais tout de même une
secousse qui a été ressentie
principalement dans les pyrénées près de
bagnères de bigorre et qui prouve que la
france n'est pas à l'abri de tels faits
le même dominique verdeilhan deux très
légère fissure d andré résidence de
vacances des pans de murs qui ont
quelque peu jouer des enfants évacués
par précaution ce sont les rares
conséquences de la secousse tellurique
d'hier soir à la station de ski la
mongie près de bagnères de bigorre zone
épicentrale de ce mini tremblement de
terre dont les effets ont été ressenti
dans tout le sud ouest du pays comme un
drame boom comme une explosion j'ai cru
que steve d'avalanche ce qui m'a le plus
étonné c'est le bruit avant j'ai crié je
suis sorti dehors passer le mur des sons
je croyais avec quelqu'un de la maison
une secousse qui n'a donc rien à voir
avec celle qui avait détruit en partie
le village d'arette en 67 dans les
basses pyrénées néanmoins d'une
magnitude de 4,5 sur l'échelle de
richter qui en compte neuf
elle inquiète les sismologues pour qui
la région de la mongie et conscience
brière c'est une secousse suivie de
toutes petites secousses de magnitudes
beaucoup plus faible pendant une heure
et depuis rien du tout
néanmoins on peut pas exclure que
d'autres secousses de magnitudes du même
ordre puisse intervenir dans les jours
qui viennent
comme on ne peut pas savoir si la
magnitude sera plus importante ou moins
important il y a néanmoins toutes
raisons de penser que la mine étude sera
du même ordre ou plus faibles les
sismographes se sont également
légèrement affolé dans les environs de
l'etna dont l'activité actuellement
s'accroît ainsi qu'en suisse avec une
amplitude de 3,8 une région où la terre
tremble en moyenne une dizaine de fois
par an la politique française élections
municipales pierre joxe le ministre de
l'intérieur demande une enquête sur les
révisions de listes électorales à paris
la municipalité de jacques chirac est en
effet accusée d'avoir inscrit sur ses
listes plusieurs centaines de personnes
habitant en fait en banlieue et de les
avoir domiciliés dans les quartiers les
plus menacées de paris c'est-à-dire dans
l'est de la capitale un communiqué de la
mairie de l'hôtel de la de l'hôtel de
ville ce soir juge cette démarche du
ministre de l'intérieur intempestives et
inspiré par des motifs partisans dans la
mesure où dit ce communiqué les
décisions d'inscription ou de radiation
relève de commissions composées à parts
égales de représentants de la justice de
la préfecture et de la municipalité
affaire à suivre donc
l'organisation écologiste greenpeace se
refait parler d'elle elle veut empêcher
la construction par la france d'une
piste d'atterrissage dans l'antarctique
au pôle sud cet aérodrome s'inscrit en
effet dans le cadre d'une décision
internationale visant à développer les
ressources minières énorme de cette
région mais les écologistes de
greenpeace et d'autres spécialistes
comme le célèbre commandant cousteau
estime que cette industrialisation de la
banquise risque de déstabiliser
l'équilibré naturel de toute la planète
jacques violent lorsqu'il a débarqué
pour la première fois sur ce continent
immaculé cousteau s'est retourné pour
regarder ses pas dans la neige
et il a ressenti une certaine honte pour
avoir oublié de nettoyer les semelles de
ses chaussures l'antarctique un
continent blanc un désert glacé centré
sur le pôle sud à 1000 kilomètres de
l'extrême pointe de l'amérique du sud et
2005 de l'australie sa surface de 12
millions et demi de kilomètres carrés
soit près de la surface de l'europe est
le plus souvent recouvertes d'une énorme
coupole de glace de 2 km d'épaisseur
tout autour du continent circulent des
icebergs géants arraché au rivage
intérêts stratégiques d'abord politique
puis économique
cette terre glacée du bout du monde a
toujours exciter les convoitises en 1943
sept pays se sont partagés ce continent
comme un gâteau en 59 le traité de
l'antarctique et signé les
confrontations s'estompe le continent
doit être consacrée exclusivement à des
activités pacifiques
c'est à dire scientifique mais le club
de l'antarctique s'agrandit de nouveaux
pays arrive et tous installe des bases
permanentes soviétique américains
australiens japonais et français
travaille très activement depuis 30 ans
les choses se sont plutôt bien passées
même si les scientifiques pour lui
quelque peu ce désert blanc
mais depuis quelques mois 33 pays ont
signé une convention ouvrant le
continent à une exploitation des
ressources minières charbon pétrole ou
uranium l'émission de la calypso et les
hommes de la fondation cousteau ont
observé la faune et la flore ils ont
filmé les manchots les phoques les
orques ils ont plongé sous les icebergs
mais ils ont aussi remarqué une extrême
fragilité de ce continent du à la
simplicité de ses écosystèmes
aujourd'hui le commandant cousteau
alerte le monde entier il faut s'opposer
à tout prix à la ratification de cette
convention qui autoriserait
l'exploitation des richesses c'est une
convention j'allais presque dire
criminel
1 mais en tout cas stupide et qu'il faut
absolument arrêter et pour arrêter il
faut que lancent un mouvement pour
convaincre les représentants du peuple
de ne pas ratifier cette convention et
il suffirait que quatre ou cinq pays
refusent de ratifier pour que la
convention n'aboutissent pas parce que
dire aux mineurs allez on va vous
permettre d'aller là dedans mais soyez
bien propre faites attention le
continent est fragile et il faut pas
connaître les exploitations minières
pour dire des choses pareilles en plus
avec les tempêtes
on a jusqu en mer du nord les
plates-formes pétrolières peuvent faire
or les bars et noir dont la partie sera
une catastrophe
la mobilisation commence pour essayer de
sauver ce continent encore presque
vierge
greenpeace par exemple installer une
base depuis deux ans et visitent
régulièrement les installations des pays
cette organisation mène en ce moment une
action contre la construction d'une
piste d'atterrissage de plus d'un
kilomètre à la base française dumont
d'urville
les travaux commencés en 82 et 83
continue il faut raser plusieurs îlots
dynamité des roches co
une digue mais la piste française n'est
pas un cas isolé d'autres nations
contribue à la dégradation de l'unique
et fragile environnement en antarctique
oui à partir de demain dimanche
après-midi antenne 2 diffusera quatre
émissions spéciales consacrées à
l'antarctique par le commandant cousteau
et toute son équipe
voilà un dossier qui va rappeler bien
des choses au moins jeunes nés en
apprendre aux plus jeunes le châtelet
sans doute le théâtre de paris ou de
france même le plus célèbre dans tout le
pays car ces spectateurs sont autant
provinciaux que parisien le châtelet
débaptiser puis rebaptisé qui faillit en
son temps de venir comme beaucoup
d'autres théâtres un parking n'est plus
aujourd'hui sur une voie de garage il
est relancé
cette saison l'occasion pour nous de
refaire l'histoire de ce théâtre qui
abrita les plus grands noms de la danse
puis de l'opérette débat les russes à
luis mariano
claude crespo michel le vase en 1862 il
est le plus beau théâtre de paris style
renaissance italienne
on peut y voir tous les divertissements
populaires pièces unitaires vaudeville
mélo fihri et même à son origine à sir
avec un vrai manège dans le programme
d'alors dg bien sûr mais aussi du pas la
claque et la figuration souvent été
assurée par les gros chars des alpes
voulions pas c'était le quartier des
halles le ventre de paris était ton
porte du chapelet et on les ramasse et
tant bien que mal pour un sandwich ou
quelques sous comme ça c'est pour vous
dire qu'elle pouvait être l'ambiance 0
programmation avec le répertoire
traditionnel moins traditionnels un des
sommets du châtelet en 1909 les balles
et russe bien ghilès entrée du cubisme
dans l'art du valais apollinaire invente
le mot surréalisme
et nijinski s'envole vers les sphères
éthérées de la folie l'art du lyrique
n'est pas oubliée chaliapine triomphe
avec boris goudounov et de scanie me
dirige enrico caruso 1928 arrive maurice
lehmann la recette de cet ancien acteur
ne pas oublier basie ou leur union et
acclimaté les succès de broadway dès mon
arrivée je me suis dit qu'il fallait
renouveler un petit peu le genre du
châtelet et j'ai monté show boat show
boat et et une opérette américaine qui
s'est appelé mais s'ils s'y plie
l'opérette est donc née ainsi qu'une
collaboration fructueuse avec des
signatures célèbres ville met ses mots
et zions pour nina rose à 710
représentation au temps des
merveilleuses et dans l'équipe de lehman
arrive alors de la froide russie le
décorateur rt qui signera également
décors et costumes de yana avec moi y'a
que j'aurais charmant mais je dois vous
avouer que même les gens qui est réputé
qu'à voir qu'un chien possible on
séchait charmant avec moi nouvel âge
d'or après la libération avec cette
oeuvre ou mariano chante pour la
première fois du francis lopez
il a permis de créer ce nouveau genre
qui s'est implanté en france
il s'appelle l'opérette à grand
spectacle
issa t
une idole et nick qui fascinera
envoûtera même c'est tout breuses qui a
40 ans neuchâtel est derrière elle il y
avait des scènes d'hystérie aux portes
pour le voir il y avait des gens qui
venaient chaque chaque semaine le
spectacle sera joué 9 105 x 1967
marcel l'ami remplace lehmann qui fait
appel à l'équipe
lopez mariano pour le prince de madrid
mais avec la disparition de la star les
difficultés commencent 71 échec de w une
comédie musicale 1972 francis lopez
prend les rênes du théâtre et lance à
nouveau ténor josé todaro en appliquant
les recettes d'immuable de l'opérette le
merveilleux le lyrisme du rire et une
bonne musique
en quinze jours gypsy et écrit
il l'a
avec jeep s'il le châtelet à garder sa
vocation de l'opérer transition qui
avait personne qui venait et puis
pendant trois saisons
il ya eu au moins 3000 personnes à
chaque représentation
venez vous savez après le décès de
marionnaud que le châtelet allait
devenir des garages et à l'église ont
fait la messe dans un stade et paris
enverra au châtelet 1979
la ville de paris récupère le châtelet
pour en faire le théâtre musical de
paris avec un lifting coûteux 2
milliards 300 millions
en 85 black and blue un spectacle monté
par stéphane lissner trois ans plus tard
il devient le plus jeune patron du
châtelet avec pour politique un
oecuménisme elithis chaque année une
grande saison symphonique une grande
saison musicale avec un thème thème qui
est développée comme cette année avec
une intégrale gustav mahler deuxième axe
les productions lyriques chaque année
trois ou quatre productions lyriques
produite par le châtelet mais qui ont
cette particularité d'être ensuite
exportés troisième axe les grands
spectacles grand public je dirais c'est
à dire ceux qui étaient un peu
l'opérette d'avant et qui aujourd'hui
était un peu transformé sous le label de
la comédie musicale
la boucle est bouclée voilà qui n'aurait
pas déplu à luis mariano
aïe aïe aïe voilà sport pour se terminer
très dur sa décision prise cet après
midi sur le rallye paris dakar par le
responsable de l'écurie peugeot jean
todt
la victoire ne pouvant échapper en effet
à une voiture de sa marque il a décidé
de tirer au sort en lançant tout
simplement une pièce en l'air pour
savoir lequel de ces deux pilotes
vatanen ou le belge jacky ickx devait
l'emporter
patrick 9
vatanen os x quel que soit le pilote le
dakar se résume à un duel entre peugeot
et peugeot donc une victoire à coup sûr
eh bien pas du tout vatanen a encore
effectué un tonneau dans la spéciale ni
à mes gars au tout cela pour rattraper
jacky ickx son coéquipier à ce jeu là
les machines souffre tellement que jean
todt le patron de l'équipe peugeot
crains qu'aucune de ces voitures ne
finissent la course et qu'une écurie
concurrente comme celle de patrick
tambay nous retire les fruits d'un duel
fratricide
jean todt devait désigner le pilote
numéro un choix déchirant
en fait c'est une pièce de monnaie qui a
fait le choix ce sera vatanen moralité
s'il y a deux peugeot en tête à dakar x
sera deuxième dix mille kilomètres de
risques insensés à pile ou face c'est
fou non
et oui il y avait un tiercé cet après
midi vous allez voir les résultats à
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour gagner
il fallait jouer le xiii de 18 et de 17
des rapports vous les lisez et vous avez
également un kart et vous ajoutez le
disent et ça rapporte un petit peu plus
4156 francs et 80 centimes voilà ce
journal est terminée je voudrais avant
de nous quitter
vous rappeler que tout de suite après
générique il ya bien sûr josé blanc
maintien avec ses prévisions météo
philippe gassot aux environs de 23h et
puis bien sûr juste avant cela champs
elysées avec michel drucker et juste
avant de nous quitter je voudrais vous
présenter un tour de force c'est un une
édition spéciale de paris match qui a
été réalisée aujourd'hui l'empereur
hirohito est mort la nuit dernière
réalisée aujourd'hui par nos confrères
de paris match et qui sera en vente dès
lundi matin dans les kiosques un beau
tour de force donc bravo fameux
confrères de cette de ce magazine voilà
journal terminé bonne soirée sur notre
chaîne bon dimanche on se retrouve
demain à 13h bonsoir